eine frage die sich wahrscheinlich
gerade viele stellen ist kann man
tomaten im nächsten jahr wieder im
selben bett oder im selben gewächshaus
anbauen den meisten fällen kann man das
machen es gibt ein paar ausnahmen wo ich
euch dann doch empfehlen würde die
tomaten im nächsten jahr in einem
anderen bett anzubauen wenn es irgendwie
geht oder die erde auszutauschen darüber
sprechen wir am ende des videos auch
noch aber meisten von euch werden im
nächsten jahr wieder die tomaten im
gleichen gewächshaus oder beet anbauen
können so lange man so ein paar sachen
beachtet und was es da zu beachten geht
darum geht es jetzt in diesem video ich
bin normalerweise eine ganz große
verfechterin einer gut ausgeklügelten
fruchtfolge im garten das bedeutet dass
man nicht jedes jahr wieder dasselbe
gemüse im selben bett anbaut weil sich
dann in den beat krankheiten und
schädlinge festsetzen können die genau
auf dieses gemüse spezialisiert sind und
die dann im nächsten jahr natürlich ein
viel leichteres spiel haben aber bei den
tomaten ist das natürlich ziemlich
unpraktisch weil die meisten von uns ein
gewächshaus oder in tomaten häuschen
haben und dass jedes jahr umzuziehen ist
schlichtweg unmöglich aber wir haben
glück weil die tomaten sehr gut selbst
verträglich sind das heißt den macht das
gar nicht so viel aus wie anderen
gemüsen wenn sie wieder im selben bett
steht außer sie haben ein paar bestimmte
krankheiten die eben doch im boden
überwintern können darüber sprechen wie
er gleich noch aber in den meisten
fällen bekommen die tomaten ja die
braunfäule das ist so ziemlich die
häufigste tomaten krankheit dann
vielleicht noch blüten entfalle das hat
eigentlich eher mit nährstoffmangel zu
tun als dass es eine krankheit wäre und
diese ganzen sachen die über winter
nicht im boden die braunfäule kann zum
beispiel nur auf lebendigen pflanzen
überwintern und da die tomaten im herbst
sowieso irgendwann absterben und man die
dann auch aus dem gewächshaus rausnimmt
ist das gar kein problem wenn in ihrem
gewächshaus schon mal tomaten braunfäule
hatten dann bekommen die das nicht
deswegen automatisch im nächsten jahr
wieder das ist unser großes glück was
die tomaten angeht die braunfäule falls
es jemanden interessiert über winter zum
beispiel auf kartoffel knollen und so
werden die tomaten dann wieder von den
kartoffeln angesteckt aber eben nicht
von den tomaten die im vorjahr daran
erkrankt sind trotzdem möchte ich meine
tomaten biete jetzt optimal vorbereiten
damit nächstes jahr wieder die tollen
tomaten drin wachsen können und das kann
man auf verschiedene arten und weisen
machen zum beispiel bringe ich jetzt
auch gern noch mal eine schicht nur ein
kompost aus das mache ich ganz gerne
erste richtung ende des winters über den
winter eben auch nährstoffe verloren
gehen können die im kompost drin sind
gerade draußen wenn es da viel drauf
regnet deswegen bringe ich auch immer
sehr sehr gerne pflanzen coole mit in
meinem garten aus die nährstoffe die
können an der kohle andocken weil die so
eine ganz große poröse oberfläche hat
und dadurch hält die kohle die
nährstoffe im boden sozusagen fest das
ist ja auch ein bestandteil der terra
preta weiß nicht ob bedarf und schon mal
gehört hab bestimmt
nämlich richtig toll wenn man mit kohle
im garten arbeitet und gerade wenn man
angst hat dass nährstoffe ausgewaschen
werden könnten dann auf jeden fall immer
pflanzen kohle mit ausbringen aber nicht
mit grillkohle verwechseln das sind zwei
unterschiedliche sachen ihr braucht die
pflanzen kohle oder auch aktivkohle
früher habe ich das tatsächlich noch
gemacht dass ich die erde in den tomaten
beten so ungefähr 5 bis 10 cm im herbst
abgegraben habe und sie gegen frische
erde getauscht habe ein riesen aufwand
bis ich mich da mal näher mit den
pflanzen krankheiten beschäftigt habe
und gemerkt hab haye für die
allermeisten krankheiten ist das einfach
komplett unnötig die paar ausnahmen dies
ergibt die sind wirklich relativ selten
also das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
die bei euch auftreten und wenn dann
könnte es ja immer noch machen aber
vorbeugend ist es einfach ein viel zu
großer aufwand der überhaupt nicht sein
muss dazu kommt dass wir das gewächshaus
im winter ja auch für wintergemüse
nutzen wollen und die pflanze ich
normalerweise wenn die tomaten noch im
gewächshaus drin stehen da ist
eigentlich gar kein zeitpunkt wo das
gewächshaus oder auch die tomaten bietet
draußen komplett leer stehen wo man dann
die er daraus schaufeln könnte weil ich
will dass die pflanzungen sich
überlappen damit die wintergemüse dann
auch rechtzeitig groß genug sind dass
wir im winter auch eine ernte aus dem
gewächshaus rausholen können genauso wie
ich im frühjahr auch die allerersten
sachen schon so pflanze dass die tomaten
später dazwischen hoch wachsen können
und dann werden die frühlingsgemüse
irgendwann abgeerntet wenn die tomaten
den platz richtung brauchen das ist
total genial macht es einem aber sehr
schwer die erde jedes jahr auszutauschen
und deswegen sind wir glaube ich alle
proben wird es nicht machen ist kommen
wir zu den vier maßnahmen wo das
vielleicht doch sein muss es gibt so ein
paar fiese tomaten krankheiten die eben
auch im boden überwintern können das
wäre einmal divertikel umwelt wie man
die erkennt blende ich jetzt hier ein
weil ich denke dass das auf die meisten
von euch nicht zutreffen wird und dann
auch die wurzel gallen nematoden das
sind so die zwei fiese ssten wo ich
wirklich versuchen würde den boden
auszutauschen und vielleicht auch ein
jahr eine tomaten pause auf diesem beet
einzulegen und die tomaten irgendwo
anders an zu bauen wenn es irgendwie
geht also in dem fall die obersten fünf
bis 10 cm der erde abgraben und dann
durch frische erde ersetzen im fall von
der wurzel gallen methode kann man auch
versuchen im nächsten jahr veredelte
pflanzen anzubauen und auf resistente
sorten zurückzugreifen dass wir auch
noch einen punkt den ich unbedingt
beachten würde wenn ich die bei mir
hätte noch so eine fiese tomaten
krankheit ist die kurze krankheit die es
nicht ganz so schlimm meiner
einschätzung nach wie die anderen beiden
so dass man nicht unbedingt die erde
tauschen muss aber ich würde euch sehr
empfehlen in dem fall eine weitere
fruchtfolge zu den anderen
nachtschattengewächsen und auch anderen
tomatenpflanzen einzuhalten also nicht
jedes jahr wieder die tomaten im selben
haus anzubauen und nächstes jahr
unbedingt veredelte pflanzen anbauen
weil die sehr viel weniger anfällig für
diese krankheit sind dann gibt es noch
eine andere welt das wäre dann kandidat
nummer vier die ist so ähnlich wie
divertikel um welche das ist diffus ari
umwelt man kann die oft gar nicht so
leicht unterscheiden aber wenn ihr den
stängel aufschneidet und das innen drin
brauchen uns dann ist es die fusarium
welke und dann müsst ihr auch nicht
unbedingt den boden tauschen aber sollte
auf jeden fall auch bei den tomaten eine
weitere fruchtfolge einhalten hoffen wir
mal dass ihr diese tomaten krankheit
nicht bei euch im garten habt da drüben
findet ihr meine tomaten playlist mit
meinem gebündelten tomaten tipps also
gerne mal reinschauen wenn ihr euch für
die nächste saison fit machen wollt
ansonsten ist da unten ein video mit
aufgaben die jetzt im herbst im garten
wichtig sind geht raus macht die welt
ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video teams